let's bring in Asad Baek he's joining us
from the Iranian capital Tehran so as
we're saying Iran acknowledging that
people were killed by security forces
for the first time but have they said
how many people were killed well not
really the official death count here by
the Iranian government is still still
stands that 13 and that also includes
security services but you know this
country's is emerging from Internet
blackout the internet was restored last
week and videos and images are emerging
from those demonstrations now this
report where the government acknowledged
that protesters were killed was carried
by state media in a lengthy report it
was around 7 minutes long but it gave
the Iranian version of events now it
broke down those that were killed into
four categories some were called rioters
and thugs that attacked sensitive
centers and military centers armed with
firearms and knives passes passerbys and
security services and peaceful
protesters now what's interesting is
that the Iranian government hasn't said
how those peaceful protesters were
killed they were they only said that it
was suspicious and should be
investigated in fact just now this
morning the head the spokesperson of the
judiciary has said that the bullets that
killed those peaceful protesters were
not of the security services now Iran
does have a record of blaming outside
forces of interfering in Iran's affairs
and they've done the same during these
demonstrations now what's also
interesting about this report that was
carried on state media was that Iran
acknowledged the cities that the
demonstrations took place it
acknowledged that demonstrations took
place in Tehran in Shiraz Jairaj and
also the southwestern city of Michell
where there's there are allegations and
that there was a massacre but what the
report said was that there were armed
separatists that fired on security
services and security services were
forced to fire back and defend
themselves so this report was very much
a kind of defense of the security forces
in the country saying that they had to
act to defend people and save people's
lives
accusing protesters of writing and
targeting petrochemical plants which
could have risk many lives and what's
the reaction been inside Iran
well like I said the spokesman on
judiciary has been speaking this morning
he's rejected the number by in analyst
international the death toll
he said that it's there's a big
difference and that the opposition or
the outside forces are giving these
numbers to international organizations
but there's still a lot a lot of anger
and frustration inside Iran in fact a
popular opposition leader Amir Hussein
Mousavi who's been under house arrest
since 2011 he likened the crackdown on
demonstrations to the time of the Shah
we're peaceful protesters were gunned
down and led to the Islamic Revolution
so there's still a lot of anger and
frustration here and we don't really
know how many people have been killed
all right that's a big thank you